ou est-ce qu'on est aujourd'hui on est
en suède et on se le dise pasqua est
bien en suède il ya le siège de links
and cost à göteborg c'est pas très loin
d'ici vous allez voir c'est un peu le
netflix de l'automobile ce que je vais
vous présenter aujourd'hui est fou c'est
un peu révolutionnaire c'est comment ne
pas perdre de l'argent ou comment gagner
de l'argent avec sa voiture c'est une
révolution qui s'opère au niveau
l'automobile et vous allez voir le truc
c'est
[Musique]
là on est à göteborg où venait d'arriver
c'est le siège monde de links and co qui
est juste ici en plein göteborg en plein
centre il ya qu un siège monde sait ici
il y en a pas deux alors au programme de
la vidéo aujourd'hui on va vous
expliquer comment ça marche comment on
vient rentabiliser sa voiture une
voiture qu'on peut acheter une voiture
qu'on peut louer en tout convient sous
louer pour gagner de l'argent ça toi qui
est nouveau c'est une nouvelle façon de
penser une nouvelle façon de consommer
sa voiture une façon de l'utiliser et de
la partager c'est de l'auto partage les
anglais écossais du quart shearing bref
il ya plein de mots pour expliquer ça
c'est intéressant et en complément de
cette vidéo vous invite à venir voir mon
podcast sur ma chaîne fréquence
grenouille interview le boss alain de
son petit nom qui va tout nous expliquer
le business model comment ça marche
est-ce que c'est intéressant est ce que
c'est rentable bref mais dans cette
vidéo la sq on vient faire pour bien
regarder comment ça fonctionne pour voir
si vous ça peut vous intéresser pour
comprendre l'évolution de l'automobile
comme on arrive à ne plus perdre trop
d'argent que sa voiture peut-être même
en gagner allez savoir c'est parti on va
visiter l'île kenko directement à
göteborg en suède et ça c'est cool
je vais m'expliquer comment fonctionnent
les kengo qu'est ce qui se passe ici à
göteborg dans ce grand bol dit mais pour
commencer on va aller d'or regardez
regardez il en met partout du links and
co et déjà il commence avec des trucs
bizarres bien la dernière année que ce
extrêmement bizarre il vous met démarre
alors je suppose qu'ils aient une
signification je suppose ce biais
quelque chose peut-être le week-end qu
en langage des signes j'en sais rien en
tout cas il ya des mains qui sortent du
mur et vous allez voir qu'ici en
visitant vous n'allez pas être au bout
de vos surprises c'est très bizarre ce
qui se passe très étrange mais bien avec
moi ça fait partie
[Musique]
il ya un truc à connaître celle une can
co ceux qui font les choses qui est pas
tout à fait comme les autres à commencer
par ce qu'on appelle le club alors ici
c'est l'entrée du grand building du
siège bond de nintendo mais ont
reconstitué un peu l'ambiance du club
alors c'est quoi l'idée du club je vous
leur fait l'idée d'une canne causé une
voiture devait pouvoir venir soit loué
550 euros par mois soit venir acheter 40
et 1500 euros ou alors même sous louer
un véhicule de quelqu'un à soient
achetés soit loué vous avez compris
l'histoire mais ça s'arrête pas là parce
que vous avez une vie ils veulent
vraiment développer une vie dans les
clubs links and co c'est à dire un
endroit où les pouvoirs venir boire un
coup et pouvoir venir travailler c'est
du coworking avec des amis un lieu de
rencontre en lieu de vie c'est pas une
concession c'est pas un lieu de vente
c'est un lieu de vie qui permettra à la
marque dell connu et à vous de passer un
bon moment c'est un peu ça l'idée en
tout cas et on retrouve ça ici avec des
produits qu'on peut venir acheter il
travaille avec des artisans des boîtes
locales qui ont la même idée la même
culture plutôt eco friendly plutôt green
plutôt bonne pour la planète et c'est ce
qu'on va retrouver un peu ici voilà ça
c'est l'idée alors je vous fais le
concept vous avez une voiture où vous
voulez avoir une voiture et vous voulez
soit l'acheter sur la loue et c'est très
facile et bien avec l'uncam causé pour
venir louer votre voiture un mois si
vous voulez deux mois trois mois autant
que vous voulez c'est un peu comme
netflix est à dire qu'en fait vous le
loup et pour un mois et vous le résilier
à tout moment quand vous voulez donc ça
c'est simple c'est pratique et c'est
malin et si vous vous l'êtes propres et
à votre voiture c'est plus vos trucs des
propriétaires vous l'achetez pas riffs
simples 41 1500 euros vous avez donc le
choix entre ces deux idées ça c'est
simple ces forçats de base et ça marche
bien maintenant que vous avez votre
voiture vous voulez la rentabiliser en
tout cas peut-être gagner de l'argent
voire ne pas en perdre c'est l'idée de
base parce qu'aujourd'hui les voitures
ça donne quoi 96 % du temps et on perd
de l'argent parce qu'elle ne sert
strictement à rien si ce n'est être là
il pas bouger donc vous avez votre
voiture vous avez soit acheter soit loué
maintenant ce que vous faites si vous
vous êtes inscrit sur link enhco sur le
service sur leur site d'envoi de voiture
vous pouvez régler pas mal de paramètres
j'ai déjà montré mais vous faites
également dans votre smartphone et vous
dit ma voiture est disponible tel jour à
telle heure tel jour à telle heure alors
on va pas venir créer de récurrence ici
mais par contre on vient le créé au
temps de disponibilité qu'on le souhaite
et quand quelqu'un vient et bien vous
commencez à gagner de l'argent c'est
vous qui fixez votre prix un peu comme
ce qu'on aurait sur an ennemi c'est vous
qui choisissez alors pour autant il faut
rester sur une valeur moyenne correcte
pour la louer ce que si vous êtes trop
cher par rapport au marché là vous
louerez rien si vous êtes trop bas vous
allez loué à bail vous gagnerez pas
grand chose vous mettez sur la valeur
moyenne et là vous allez commencer à la
louer et à récupérer de l'argent l'idée
c'est très personnel vient elle prend la
voiture et après la ramène au même
endroit c'est totalement transparent
pour vous vous avez culte aux affaires
seuil encaissé alors vous encaissez vous
récupérer de l'argent et après vous
venez noter la personne qui a récupéré
la bagnole est ce que la voiture et
kleenex qui dans un boy's à trop porter
ce qu'ils voulaient bien garé allez
savoir pourquoi pas tous ces sujets là
sont intéressants c'est la même chose en
fait que vous devez retrouver sur airbnb
compagnie c'est un peu l'idée après de
l'ubs et risation du véhicule ou venir
le loup est très facilement cette idée
là un peu entre netflix et hubert voyez
on est dans ces nouvelles tendances
[Musique]
on part faire un tour dans la one line
qu'un coffret s'il ya un seul véhicule
est séché vinko d'ailleurs il faut
savoir que dans deux finitions ils sont
dit on va faire un truc hyper sam celik
and co c'est à dire que la voiture tu là
il n'y a aucune option celui-là soit en
bleu soit en noir voilà c'est tout comme
ça y'a pas de problème tout le monde
aura la même y'a pas de jaloux alors je
vous ai déjà fait une vidéo je vous
présentais ce véhicule donc ce que je
vous invite à faire c'est venir variés
dans la description je vous mets le lien
de la vidéo que j'ai fait avant pour
tout savoir sur ce véhicule aujourd'hui
on vraiment compter sur l'expérience
comprendre cette espèce de révolution
qui est en train d'arriver avec le
carsharing l'autopartage je prends la
route on a le temps c'est de pas me
planter parce que la suède et moi je ne
suis jamais allé je ne comprends pas en
fait là on est en hybride donc je peux
connaissez libre et d'un séchoir
électrique soit c'est le moteur qui
prend le relais je peux conduire soit en
full électrique soit en full thermique
si je le souhaite donc ne truque est
assez simple c'est plutôt pas mal je
trouve que la voiture à la vache folle
la gueule on est sur une balle de volvo
xc 40 et puis surtout les finitions sont
vachement belle la voiture est super
cool des très grands écrans intérieur je
n'ose a très rapidement au niveau de
l'habitacle et puis voilà en continuant
à nantes justement sans nous montrer le
véhicule parce qu'ils ont fait des trucs
qui sont vachement intéressant en termes
de personnalisation et d'expérience
utilisateur regardez déjà première chose
c'est extrêmement fluide pouvez ensuite
dans vos paramètres et vous allez dans
displaced à dire affichage pouvait venir
choisir le thème qui va venir s'afficher
devant vous ça c'est thème par défaut
très simple mais vous avez d'autres
thèmes par exemple vivid donc là on est
des couleurs un petit peu plus
viola c'est qu'ils sont sympas on a un
thème classique ou là j'ai un côté un
petit peu argentés puis aussi très sympa
blaise et là j'ai encore avoir un
affichage qui est totalement différent
on peut venir changer ça très rapidement
et je trouve que c'est vachement
intéressant parce qu'en fait ça vient
personnalisées directement l'expérience
que vous allez avoir avec votre véhicule
et ça ça ajoute vraiment mais vraiment
l'expérience comme je voulais biais de
couleurs il ya le bleu et le noir donc
toutes les voitures se ressemblent donc
en fait ce que vous allez faire quand
vous allez venir ici vous allez vous
identifier à travers vos smartphones et
vous allez ouvrir votre voiture
directement une mode smartphone donc le
truc qui est super c'est qu'en fait la
voiture va venir s'adapter totalement à
vos réglages donc vous allez retrouver
tous vos paramètres le siège parce
qu'elle est selon-vous paramètres
directement le volant bref tout va être
complètement adapté à vos paramètres
donc vous allez louer des voitures qui
vont pas être les mêmes à chaque fois
mais pour autant l'expérience sera
similaire et ça c'est vachement cool
c'est hyper malin la joue donc à tafas
pour comprendre comment on vient mettre
en location son véhicule donc ça c'est
mon propre vécu les jeux le mettre en
location je clique ici sur cher now
alors vous l'aurez traduit en français
pour l'instant ici on est en suède donc
c'est en anglais vous choisissez vous
avez votre voiture bon j'en ai qu'une
c'est celle-là je choisis à partir de
quel moment je vais venir la louer là
par exemple à 3h16 il est 3h 16 allez on
va se dire dans 10 minutes à peu près en
grosso modo hockey j'enregistre et je
dis que je vais la loue et jusqu'au 8
donc aujourd'hui allez on va se dire
jusqu'à 7 heures du soir l'heure à
laquelle je préfère du travail jeu mais
ok et là j'ai pu qu'à cliquer sur sheikh
now et là ma voiture est directement en
location donc on retrouve l'endroit où
est la voiture l'adresse exacte pour les
personnes qui viendront le louer à
partir de caen jusqu'à quand et mon
partage qui est là et ensuite je pourrai
revenir gérer directement toutes mes
réservations alors pour l'instant j'en
ai pas mais lorsque j'en aurai je
pourrais venir les voir si besoin je
pourrais les annuler et vient les
consulter tout ça ça se fait directement
ici depuis l'interface c'est quand même
vachement pratique donc je stoppe sa et
si je veux le mettre sur plusieurs jours
eh bien regardez dit aujourd'hui mais je
peux également dire demain après demain
après après demain en gros je peux dire
que mon véhicule est disponible pendant
plusieurs jours c'est par exemple chez
en déplacement je le met en location et
ensuite les personnes pour ne reprendre
pour une heure pour deux heures pour une
journée pour deux jours en fonction de
leurs besoins donc c'est très complet
sur ça vachement pratique
et là où le sujet morts waouh c'est le
truc est là où le sujet est marrant
c'est que votre smartphone vient se
positionner au centre de tout ça que
vous soyez là personne qui loue le
véhicule ou celui qui le met en location
si vous louez votre véhicule sur votre
smartphone vous venez tout planifié très
facilement donc vous l'avez avec vous
vous pouvez être chez vous au travail
tiens vous décidé de louer vous voyez
qu'il loue très facilement directement
donc ça c'est vachement cool et de la
même manière vous voulez louer un
véhicule vous avez votre application et
vous regardez dans tous les cas vous
êtes membre links and co ça c'est cool
et l'idée qui marrante derrière en fait
c'est de venir tout positionné au centre
avec son smartphone et je vous parle
beaucoup de smartphones parce que c'est
mon truc sur la chaîne c'est en fait le
smartphone est au centre de votre vie
connectée on en parle on en parle on ne
repart et même là votre smartphone
devient clé pour déverrouiller votre
voiture alors si on l'a déjà vu avec
plein de véhicules haut de gamme que ce
soit chez bmw que ce soit chez tesla ça
existe on le voit un peu partout et dans
cette idée voyez le carsharing de
location je trouve ça extrêmement malin
et ça rend un service de dengue la joue
contre le principe pour venir louer en
fait regarder son à carte moi je suis là
je peux venir chercher dans göteborg
alors on va venir des zooms un peu vrai
y en a quand même plutôt pas mal allez
on revient par là je vais avoir
différents prix là par exemple voyagent
en ait un sens couronne alors forcément
c'est la monnaie locale parce qu on est
en suède c'est peter k 5 étoiles qui est
très bien noté mme adjani qui est
beaucoup moins cher à deux couronnes
c'est david donc là je peux venir la
loue et si je veux mais je regarde
regarde et hop là je clic à partir de
quand donc à partir de tout de suite par
exemple ça m'intéresse mais si je veux
louer que demain et bien demain je peux
donner l'heure je dis ok on peut faire
ça je sauvegarde et ensuite l'heure de
faim alors ça peut être effectivement
pour une heure ça peut être pour deux
heures et ça peut être aussi pour deux
trois jours en fonction de mes besoins
et je mets deux jours là et là ça va
venir me proposait dans l'application en
fait tous les véhicules qui sont
disponibles cette période c'est à dire
ça pas forcément tous les véhicules
parce qu'il ya des gens qui vont
l'utiliser le soir pour rentrer chez eux
qui ont auront besoin il y en a d'autres
qui vont la mettre à disposition pendant
plusieurs jours donc là forcément les
tarifs s'ajuste sont plus élevés parce
que sur une période de deux jours et en
fonction des paramètres que je vais
rentrer bien je vais voir quels sont les
véhicules disponibles donc c'est
complètement adaptatif c'est plutôt pas
mal je vais avoir ensuite des ficus
fournier appliquée et le truc qui est
intéressant ce qui ailleurs des notes
j'ai pouvant dire qu'afin par exemple
qu'à une note de 3 ou une autre de 2 bat
je vais pas venir lui louer je vais
prendre quelqu'un qui a une haute de 5
ça peut venir me rassurer alors de la
même manière en fait que ce qu'on va
retrouver sur toutes les applications au
type airbnb une fois que c'est terminé
que j'ai fini de nous un véhicule je la
prends en photo des quatre côtés pour
dire regardez dans quel état je voulait
restituer et ensuite peut mettre une
note à la personne qui va me louer le
véhicule et la même manière la personne
qui m'a elle louait le véhicule va
mettre une note pour dire si je suis
sérieux ou pas je pense bien gérer ici
directement les locations que j'ai fait
alors pour l'instant il y en a pas donc
forcément je ne les ai pas fait je n'ai
pas louer fatalement mais voilà tout
c'est quand même plutôt intéressant
c'est très clair c'est intuitif on
navigue sur une carte on voit les tarifs
on peut venir à révéler tous ces
paramètres ça peut paraître assez
contradictoire mais quand on parle
automobile on parle assez peu eco
friendly on parle assez peu durabilité
écologique n'est pas des sujets qui vont
trop bien ensemble et en fait la salle
devient l'idée linkous et de se dire ça
sert à rien qu'on est tous une voiture
il ya des voitures qui dorment tout le
temps il ya des besoins les voitures
elles sont là elles existent pourquoi
venir tous avoir notre propre bagnols
pour les faire dormir donc c'est l'idée
fait je trouve ça en fait c'est assez
malin d'un point de vue écologique et ça
a vraiment un sens à une vision derrière
voyez on n'est pas juste sur des mecs
qui sont là pour vous vendre les
baigneurs l'idée c'est de se dire on va
vers la mobilité du futur alors ça
passera bien évidemment la mobilité du
futur à une partie d'automobiles parce
qu'on en a besoin on a déjà parlé sur
des véhicules qui existent aujourd'hui
mais sur des véhicules qui n'existe pas
encore aujourd'hui qu'ils existeront
demain tout ce qui va être véhicules
autonomes qui seront pilotés avec de la
5g bref on a déjà parlé des sujets mais
c'est encore un petit peu lointain mais
tout de suite mais sur une période de
transition c'est à dire qu'on connaît
les véhicules actuels où on va tous pour
apprendre votre bagnole aller nous
balader tout seul avec des amis ou même
en faisant du covoiturage mais prendre
la voiture qu'il nous appartient pas et
aller se balader avec la reposer une
heure après et que ça te coûte forcément
pas grand chose parce qu'il ya derrière
un business ou où chacun va faire un peu
son prix eh ben ça c'est assez nouveau
c'est assez malin et je trouve que
l'idée derrière la logique de linkin qu
elle est là et on le voit ici parce que
le bâtiment il fout parce qu'on voit que
les mecs ils ont une vision qui quand
même un peu à part est sûre ça cool
c'est marrant ce histoire de club alors
poêlé au club c'est très simple et se
fichent de s'inscrire heynckes est
inscrit sur l'application vous aviez au
club c'est gratos c'est marrant parce
qu'en fait si vous vous dites tiens je
suis créateur je suis indépendant j'en
sais rien je viens de créé mon business
ou alors juste pas bosser de chez moi et
vous avez qu à vous inscrire sur
nintendo est allé bosseur un club alors
tout de suite il n'y a pas encore de
club à paris il y en a pas encore en
france qui aura peut-être un qui va
arriver à paris à la fin de l'année
peut-être un lion c'est pas ça devrait
arriver donc bon suivait l'histoire et
vous saurez tout et puis surtout pas ce
qui m'intéresse chez links and co voyez
c'est ce que vous allez avoir d'inclure
ce que vous louez votre voiture lorsque
vous allouez à 550 euros par mois vous
avez l'entretien avait des pneus alors
si vous êtes dans une région où c'est
obligatoire d'avoir des pneus d'hiver et
bien vous allez avoir vos pneus d'hiver
qu'on va venir vous changer mais qu'on
va bien vous changer dans une concession
volvo pourquoi et bien parce que il ya
un peu une histoire de famille j'ai bien
compris entre links and co et volvo
faisait donc l'entretien vous avez plein
de choses et même l'assurance de compris
dedans et lorsque vous sous louer le
véhicule vous avez également une
assurance qui est différente de
l'assurance du propriétaire ou du
locataire du véhicule donc ce soir le
locataire ou le sous locataire vous avez
chacun votre assurance qui était que si
vous soulevez et que vous défoncer la
bagnole pour la zone pour une autre ne
fait pas attention à vous et aux
véhicules eh bien elle est couvert par
l'assurance du sceau locataires et ça
n'impacte pas du tout le l'assurance du
locataire donc ya pas de perte de points
de bonus malus et des choses comme ça
donc ça c'est aussi assez rassurant le
truc qui est intéressant là dedans c'est
de comprendre les valeurs de la marque
parce que linkem qu alors moi je m'en
fous j'suis pas piqué d'une canne comme
est ce que je comprends ce que je vois
en visitant en fait c'est aussi en
découvrant la marque c'est que il essaie
de se projeter dans l'avenir se dire que
l'automobile telle qu'on la connaît
aujourd'hui on est plutôt sur la fin on
est sur une nouvelle histoire qui
s'écrit et ils veulent aller là dedans
alors je suis convaincu que leur modèle
il n'est pas fait pour durer 50 ans
entend 200 ans clairement non leur
modèle sa monnaie de transition entre
tout le monde a une bagnole et entre
plus personnels voiture alors plus
personnels voiture oui et non mais en
tout cas les voitures devront beaucoup
plus partagée on les conduira pas elles
seront autonomes et intelligente donc on
va là dedans on se dirige sauf qu'on n'y
est pas encore mais entre ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui plus tôt hier un peu
aujourd'hui est ce qu'on aura à part
quelques bonnes années quelques très
bonnes années il faut un milieu il faut
trouver une façon de réécrire un peu
l'histoire alors on voit bien que ton
mobile ce serait un vente serait écrit l
électrique d'un côté on voit qu'à ce
système d'autopartage car sharing et
tout ça qui arrive donc c'est une
alternative qui est intéressante moi j'y
crois c'est parce que je pense que on
vous pas tous acheter des voitures où on
n'a pas à 550 euros 1 m pour une voiture
gère 550 onces également gros budget
vous savez le revenu je crois que le
revenu moyen français ses 1700 euros
nets 1700 1800 euros net et si vous avez
1700 1800 euros net vous allez mettre
150 euros dans une voiture je pas
convaincu si vous gagnez moins n'en
parlons même pas pour tourner va pas
pouvoir se louer une voiture à ce prix
là et tout le monde va pas pouvoir
s'acheter voiture à 41 1500 euros alors
pour autant vous me direz ok je
l'apprends 550 euros et puis si j'arrive
à la louer que je me sors sont à 200
euros avec mon véhicule je l'appelais
plus de 300 mal c'est vrai sauf que
c'est un risque que vous prenez donc il
faut être sûr pour le financer pita sont
derrière il y aura une garantie
financière que vous que même s'ils
voulaient sous-louer pas vous soyez en
capacité financière la rembourser donc
il faut quand même les revenus
conséquence que 150 euros ça reste une
grosse somme
néanmoins si vous avez ce véhicule à 550
euros et que vous avez la capacité
financière vous rendez deux services le
premier vous le rendez à vous parce que
pouvait la rentabiliser gagner de
l'argent en tout cas moins en perdre ça
c'est pas mal et puis deuxième c'est bon
pour la planète parce que la voiture
elle dort pas ça évite à quelqu'un de
prendre une voiture de l'acheter si ça
donc l'histoire elle est cool et je
trouve intéressante est derrière cette
histoire il ya une vision et cette
vision on vous en parle dans le podcast
sûrement notre chaîne qui est la chaîne
fréquents heureux où je parle avec le
big boss avec le seuil haut de la boîte
qui vous explique en fait sa vision
alors on reprend un peu tous ces
éléments pour comprendre un peu pour
resituer mais on voit la vision on voit
où on nous emmène et on voit dans quel
monde on part au niveau l'automobile
donc venez jeter un oeil ou une oreille
ce que c'est un podcast on peut le
regarder et on peut l'écouter et c'est
intéressant voilà parce que je voulais
partager avec vous alors on me dira ah
ouais ok c'est l'automobile c'est un peu
différent c'est moi avec moi et non
parce qu'en fait on se projette vraiment
futur on va regarder loin devant et on
regarde comment on amorce cette
transition avec des objets du quotidien
qu'on a tous vous avez un smartphone et
vous avez une bagnole pour 10 20 30
euros pour 1h 2h 3h sa course
intéressante et moi ce que vous en
pensez vous embarquent commentaires qu
est ce que vous pensez de cette solution
de partage d'automobiles est ce que vous
pourriez le faire est ce que vous
pourriez soit loué soit acheter un
véhicule et le sous-louer derrière parce
qu'il ya plein de gens qui disent à
temps c'est ma bagnole c'est mon
intérieur je peux partager mon p'tit
bazar j'ai pas envie qu'un inconnu puis
ce soir là où je suis pas vu qu'on
puisse poser les mains sur mon volant ou
alors est ce qu a contrario vous vous en
fichez complètement c'est pas un sujet
pour vous et dès lors qu'on peut rendre
service un peu à la planète à
l'environnement ou alors rentabiliser un
peu l'histoire 70 classes que c'est
vachement intéressant et puis moi je
trouve ça chouette parce que l'histoire
allait là l'histoire elle évolue
l'histoire elle elle est nouvelle et
quand on voit des gens qui sont des
entrepreneurs qui met les moyens alors
je pense que derrière il y a des très
gros moyens attendus on va pas créer
fina automobile aujourd'hui avec une
vision faut être un industriel faut
avoir les moyens beaucoup d'argent c'est
une grosse histoire attendons qu'il se
raconte ici mais c'est hyper hyper hyper
passionnant donc on en reparlera de tout
ça je sais pas de quelle manière mais en
tout cas l'automobile connecter sans un
sujet intéressant parce que d'avenir
parce que du présent et
on voit comment on arrive à faire
coexister un écosystème de produits et
je veux sa passion voilà donc prenez
soin de vous j'embrasse des bisous moi
je retourne ciao
[Musique]